il faut prêter sa crypte sous les amis
des
entre les ports et et sa crypte au 110 m
sans talons
[Musique]
sacripant ce show la pente n'est pas
toujours bon moment on voit le
message pour voir si tu es sage de
répondre ah tu pourra compter sur le
mois si tu es méchant sa clique tumeur
m
bonjour les petits enfants sages
je m'appelle perdre lipopette et moi
c'est trippant nous viendrons tous les
soirs à la même heure faire avec vous le
point des petits enfants sages
grâce à cette machine nous pouvons
savoir sans possibilité d'erreurs tous
ceux qui ont bien travaillé ce qu'ils
sont gentils avec leur petite soeur ou
leur petit frère et tous les soirs nous
désignerons les six enfants qui ont été
les plus sages
vous voyez mon pupitre de commande
je vais tourner la manivelle vous verrez
apparaître sur cet écran de télévision
la carte de france s'il n'ya pas de
nuage c'est que tous les enfants ont été
sages mais où le repas de noël il y en
aura tant qu'on ne verra pas la fra ne
l'écoutait pas vous allez pas aller
attention un deux trois retours
vous voyez qu'il n'ya pas besoin sans
sage en france oui oui il ya bien que le
connu à vos bons mais vraiment pas
beaucoup
seulement si vous voulez me faire
plaisir
il faut faire encore un petit effort
j'aimerais tant pour clouer le bec de
sacripant qu'il n'y ait plus un seul
nuage sur toute la france
maintenant voyons où sont les six petits
enfants les plus sages
ici nous allions voir de plus près ce
qu'a donné un ton de manivelle 1 2 3
tonnes est son petit garçon ou une
petite fille ses deux garçons
elie baup est comment s'appelle-t-il ça
marche ça marche
allez encore un tour est top
un c est ce que ça peut bien
mayotte je suis sûr que c'est une clause
wii ou camille casimir sur hull
christophe charle comment il s'appelle
patience mon ami attention ce moment est
décisif
1 2 3 tian nino qui habite 1 rue
clair-logis à alès a été très sage et au
plus ils travaillent bien à l'école
bravo christian je te félicite
et puis je te dis aussi bon anniversaire
avec un peu de retard mais j'espère que
tu ne m'en voudra pas il manquerait plus
que ça il n'oublie pas petit christian
maintenant que tu as été cité au
palmarès dix enfants sages tu ne dois
plus jamais être me chambrent ne l'a
jamais été
c'est vous qui le dites maintenant
voyons le deuxième enfant sage cité
et oui il n'ya pas que des petits
garçons qui soit sage comment il
s'appelle on va voir ça ces hommes
clotilde ou chantaient ou clair que
l'ère des remous court 13 avenue message
et le bois bryas heures à roissy en brie
fpt clair non seulement tu es très sage
mais aussi très raisonnable ça je te
félicite mythique le suivant à voile à
poitiers
et c'est un garçon qui a gagné sa fille
attends je vais trop vite ma machine va
exploser papeete
saperlipopette où sont mes lunettes
il est malade en titrant un petit garçon
dont le nom commence par e1 f
elle fera sa félicien moi j'aime bien
félicien 9
frédéric frédéric audineau qui habite 6
rue du my appartement 15 à poitiers je
suis très content mon petit frédéric que
tu sois bien ça tout en plus que tu as
eu très mal quand tu t'es cas si l'agent
lui et tu as été bien courageux
mondement moi j'aurais pleuré beaucoup
plus que toi il n'a que 5 ans j'ai deux
mois dans le plâtre c'est pas trop long
et puis avec les autres enfants sages tu
seras récompensé de ta gentillesse et
son courage en suivant 1
nous voici à bully les mines
et c'est encore un petit garçon coin je
sais comment il s'appelle
oui oui messieurs oui mais comment
commence open ben jacques tu te crois
plus fort que ma machine
on va bien voir
tu t'es tu en paies 1 c'est un peu vous
c'est facile c'est votre machine qui
fait tout le travail
un os comme stoner
olivier olivier meunier olivier meunier
34 rue jean jaurès à bully les mines pas
de calais bravo à lui je suis bien
content que tu ailles à l'école
maternelle depuis la rentrée et que tu
sois bien ça tu sois la récompense et
continue à bien travailler à être gentil
regarde bien cette émission jusqu'au
bout mais tu auras une surprise à ewen
ont maintenant
[Musique]
some fresque à paris et nous allons voir
une petite fille
1 une autre petite fille votre machine
est détraquée ont dû tout entendu tout
tu vas voir je vous l'avais bien dit que
c'est ça ne veut rien dire si monsieur
je sais tout ça veut dire qu'il y a deux
petites filles sages dans la même maison
qui ont un prénom qui commence par c tu
vois tu vois christelle leclerc qui a eu
qu à temps et catherine leclerc qui va
en avoir 3 le 2 mars prochain 20 rue
barbès à montreuil 93 cents gestion des
petites cousines qui sont très sages
quand leur mamie s'absente quelques
instants elles ne font jamais de bêtises
ah ça c'est très bien c'est très bien je
vous félicite toutes les deux mois je
vous embrasse aussi les jeunes nouveaux
propos du lit sacripant et bien voici
donc terminer notre premier palmarès des
enfants ça maintenant
écoutez moi bien oui oui et il est bien
triste et les catherine de claire de
montreuil
olivier meunier de bully-les-mines
frédéric audineau de poitiers claire
verbe cours de roissy en brie et
christian mais renault d'alès
vous allez ouvrir votre porte
un préposé des ptt vous attend pour vous
remettre un colis à mon signe allez-y
dans ces colis il y à des jouets et des
vivres vous voyez bien mes petits mais
la sagesse est toujours récompensé enfin
presque toujours
mais n'oubliez pas que ma machine ne se
trompe jamais et des îles six enfants
les plus sages
parmi tous ceux qui regardent antenne 2
si vous avez été sages
il faut l'être encore davantage alors
faites un petit effort et nous aurons la
joie de vous voir et de vous récompenser
vont soir les petits enfants sages
il est l'heure maintenant d'aller au
dodo à demain soir pour ce fameux soir
bonsoir